Today we begin the return to the people,
we understand that it is time to
continue our fight
, comrades who fell in the revolutionary struggle were remembered,
Mayor Marcos, but I look at the whole face,
guys, today I want to introduce a
new comrade named Ernesto and he
came to  live in our neighborhood
but I wouldn't call them minutes and I'm
how did you find out about justice popular justice crap
the boys are in perfect health and are
leading a normal life it seems
normal to me that a boy has the name of
I don't know who the birthday
and if they have to be  in danger killing
people
we have to one of the house for
security he
is playing a shot